A FRAMEWORK HERE.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY BEAT THE
CLOCK AT MIDNIGHT.
>> Sean: ED HENRY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS WITH US.
THE ONE THING THAT -- TWO THINGS
STRUCK ME TODAY.
MICK MULVANEY WAS SPEAKING TO
THE PRESS, HOW IGNORANT JIM
ACOSTA IS THAT YOU NEED 60
VOTES.
NUMBER 2, THIS DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE PAINFUL.
OBAMA AND THE DEMOCRATS MADE IT
MORE PAINFUL THAN IT NEEDED TO
BE.
THAT WON'T BE THE CASE THIS
TIME.
>> LOOK AT THE DISAPPEARANCE
APPROACH OF THIS PRESIDENT FROM
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
HE WAS ENTERTAINING NEGOTIATIONS
AND LISTENING TO PEOPLE
PATIENTLY.
I WITNESSED SOME OF IT.
THIS PRESIDENT SUPPORTS A LONGER
TERM DEAL.
WE HAVE THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY THAT HAS
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS BENEFITS
FROM PAY RAISES.
HE VOTED AGAINST THE TAX CUTS
AND 20,000 JOBS FROM APPLE THIS
MONTH.
THE SAME THING IS HAPPENING FOR
THEY ARE AGAINST THE MILTARY AND
MILITARY IS IMPERILLED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE AGAINST CHIPS
A CHILDREN'S HEALTH PLAN.
ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR IS A
LONGER TERM DEAL THAT FUND OUR
MILTARY AND GETS THAT WALL, THE
DACA.
THERE IS A DEADLINE APPROACHING
TONIGHT BUT IT'S NOT DACA.
THAT'S IN MARCH.
YOU ARE STARTING TO SEE SOME
DEMOCRATS PEEL OFF.
THE LEFT WING FOLKS FOR 2020,
THEY ARE PEELING OFF FROM THE
LEADERSHIP AND SAYING THEY CAN
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
>> Sean: THIS IS SO IMPORTANT ON
SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS.
WE WILL HAVE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
THEY HAVE TO WORK BUT MAY NOT
GET PAID.
THAT'S HURTING THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN WHO DO THESE GREAT
JOBS.
FIREMEN AND ETC. IF IT'S ONLY
UNTIL FEBRUARY 8th, DOES CHUCK
HE IS TRYING TO THREATEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH A BIG
SHUTDOWN?
THAT'S THE ANSWER HE AND PELOSI
USED 5 YEARS AGO.
>> THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
WAS SAID ON TV TODAY.
MANY DEMOCRATS TOOK ON THE AIR
WAVES AND SAID THE REPUBLICANS
WILL BE BLAMED FOR THIS.
THEY CONTROL THE HOUSE, SENATE
AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU NEED 60 VOTES.
THAT'S THE WRONG WAY OF LOOKING
AT.
THIS IS ONLY ONE MAJOR MOVEMENT
RESISTANCE.
AMERICA KNOWS WHO THAT IS.
DEMOCRATS PRIDE THEMSELVES ON
RESISTANCE AND HOLDING UP THE
STOP SIGN.
THEY ARE GETTING IN THE WAY OF
PEOPLE GET THEIR PAYCHECK.
THIS IS THE PAYCHECK PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP VERSUS FOLKS WHO
ARE SO PETTY ABOUT DACA BEFORE
THE DEADLINE EVEN IS UPON US.
THEY WOULD DENY PEOPLE THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
THAT IS REGRETTABLE.
I HOPE THEY CHANGE THEIR MIND.